hello there what's hot is warm yeah now
we did this in Alabama with tiny little
pots of paint very high frame rates now
we're gonna step up the size we've got
bigger bangers
yeah these are about five times the size
so yeah that one I was sort of like
stood there didn't really care that much
we starting sweats from still examine
Alabama sweats see what though well I'm
not standing anywhere near these there
are some of these videos where it's like
yeah whatever
Boosh I'm scaling this one yeah I'm
actually worried I think the glass
scared flying everywhere it's not a good
idea
alright so don't do it you might want to
protect her eyes as well some paint
maybe try and get them as close together
as possible
yeah and then don't push you out
literally you got time yeah okay plunge
em in properly and then run yeah are you
ready yeah right so start here yeah Hey
three two one light
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
laughing yeah and I'm bleeding out my
finger now oh yeah
lovely guy is urinating blood it's gone
pretty deep
I think it's gloss still in there
alright judging by the blood Oh message
to the audience oh is that the most
severe injury we've had so far but that
was probably the most out of control
didn't know what was gonna happen one
yeah that was the scariest one that
we've ever done
yeah yeah feels really weak but it's
bleeding through the plaster and the
thick bandages all under this glass
still in it still really oh so let's
look at this your actual blood it looks
like all the other stains on your lab
coat but it's actually your real human
blood dad yeah all right what we doing
now I'm gonna mix two colors of paint
pop and then get two bangers on a stick
each one dipping as deep into the pot as
I can then just off take it you gotta
sit between them yeah do you reckon your
flinch alright this one is called the
lab coat Runa
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's right on the legs
God's sake a splotch directly in the
middle Oh anywhere that ring just
hanging in the tree there remains you
look good let's have a run-through of
what we've achieved in Bangor week all
the damage this week to me I start with
is my fingers been basically blown off I
should not have stepped on this that is
Oh me
all right well after we got done filming
that video Dan who's in the British Army
went on tour to Afghanistan and after
about a month of being there his finger
still hurt he had this weird lump over
the side of his knuckle the wouldn't
heal so we got an x-ray and it turned
out that he did indeed have a chunk of
glass lodged against his knuckle that is
disgusting so they took it out for him
and now he's got a couple of stitches in
the side of his finger so he's all fixed
so moral of the story is don't put a
banger in a glass jar and be less than a
foot away from it when it goes off
because it's really dumb you'll get more
wood alright I hope you enjoyed banger
week be sure to follow us both on
Twitter and check back again soon
there'll be a new video
you
[Music]